Hey Dan, how's it going? Hey, you go, sir.
Rob's mind if I ask you a few questions.
Let's do it. All right. Well, uh, how much
do you sleep every night? About six hours.
Where do you live in Amsterdam. Where
did you study at Columbia University.
What's your favorite book?
The road by Cormac Mccarthy.
What is the coolest deep learning project
you've seen open mind by Andrew Trask?
Do you need to know very complex math at
the level of calculus or linear Algebra
to start on the path of
deep learning? No. In fact,
you just need to know programming
and if you can code with carrots,
you can do this stuff in
nine or 10 lines of code.
If you want to get more advanced
than you'll use some math.
How long did it take you to get into
the machine learning? It took me,
I was on and off for about three years,
but to really get started,
it took me about three months.
I live in a developing country.
How can I make a positive change here?
Through machine learning there is always
an opportunity to use machine learning
in some way. Find a problem that you
want to solve, that's the first step.
And once you do apply
machine learning to it,
you can always do that in
order to master deep learning.
Is there any other language we
should learn other than python?
Javascript comes in at a close second,
uh,
and also go is a great language.
Which courses did you take it you
need that you would recommend? Uh,
at my university, uh,
there were, I mean it was,
it was a closed university,
but online I can say a great
course to take is that you Udacity,
deep learning Nano degree as well
as Andrew new deep learning course.
Can Ai be used to retouch skin
portions by removing blemishes?
Like with Photoshop? Oh, for
sure. Yeah, that would be a, uh,
there'll be a generative problem for,
you'd want to,
you'd want to use an autoencoder to
encode that image and then you would learn
the latent representation and then you
could generate an image without the
blemishes. Which country would
you like to visit most? Uh,
I'm really excited to go to India
in five days, so I will be in India.
I'm very excited and if
you've started today,
which learning resource would
you use? Domestic, deep learning.
I wonder what I would
use my channel for sure.
My channel and also I would look at you,
Udacity and Coursera.
How can introverted or shy people improve
their confidence to be more like you
as these traits are helpful in tech?
It just takes a lot of practice.
I'm not naturally a super social person
but but just by constantly putting
myself out there in front of the world,
being vulnerable,
it definitely just builds
up your confidence so it's
a discipline that you build
up over time.
What drives you to create Youtube Khan
contents instead of working on some high
end AI or machine learning
research independently or
collaboratively with great
minds of our time.
I would love to do a project that is
put in the hands of millions of users,
but it's kind of a sacrifice, right?
Making content is my way of making impact.
I could do one or the other. Ideally
I could do both. We'll see. We'll,
we'll see where that goes.
Have you ever tried clarifies
cool image recognition technology,
which is a direct competitor to Google.
I have,
I think it's really easy
to use and a thumbs up.
What do you think about independent
startups competing with big giants and Ai
Tech such as Google, Microsoft, Amazon,
and why would you prefer one over the
others such as clarify versus Google?
There is definitely a space
for startups for sure.
There's so many different exit strategies
are so much different data that's
available for small startups that you
can use that Google or Amazon or the
giants haven't used yet. There's the
space is really hot. So don't be,
don't be discouraged by the fact that
Google and all these big companies exist.
Okay.
Well if you are an element,
what element would you be called
and what would your properties be?
I would be Saroj IOM and
my properties would be
dreaming big and competence and science,
scientific thinking. Lots of
managers lack an understanding of it.
And what ml is capable of.
And your experience,
how would you best manage the expectations
of what is possible and what is
realistic? Uh, well yeah,
I mean the standard rules rules apply
of under promising and over delivering.
So just you'd have to have a good
knowledge of your problem domain first.
And if you do, then be able to
say what you can and cannot do.
Don't just make bs promises
cause that's gonna Backfire.
Do you stand for net neutrality
and how is it important to you? Oh,
for sure the Internet is,
it has to be a level playing field.
I mean I went from zero to I think 170
k subscribers just on my own so far.
And uh, yeah, if, if net
neutrality didn't exist,
the top creators on Youtube would
just get higher and higher in terms of
subscribers and I would still be
at zero to 30 k subs. We need it.
How do I start my journey as
a tech speaker? Uh, somewhere,
right?
I mean you always have meetups near you
just do something small and work your
way up. Build a name for yourself,
your name is your brand build.
It starts somewhere.
Do you get sponsored by conference
organizers for your talks?
I have been offered and I've just
started to do the whole speaking thing in
person. I mean I could just
make videos. Uh, so yeah,
I'm going to start charging
soon cause it takes a time,
time sacrifice away from my other content.
When did you start with machine
learning? I started, I mean it's,
it's kind of ambiguous. Like I started
in college when I was a sophomore,
you know,
I dabbled in it but I only
really seriously got started
about a year and a half
ago when I started this channel.
What problems could you result with
deep learning technology in 10 years?
Me personally or just in general?
A lot of applications in healthcare,
uh,
taking away a lot of the grunt
work that doctors have to do.
And also in democratizing data,
there's a huge opportunity there because
everybody wants data but data isn't
accessible to everybody.
So any kind of project that does that
helps with that is that is a good
opportunity. Do you watch any TV
shows like silicon valley, Mr,
robot or Westworld and if you've
watched them, what do you think?
I have heard of them. I've seen the
first episode of Silicon Valley,
it's too much like my life,
so I'm not going to watch it.
I actually don't have time to
watch that much long form content.
I watch a lot of youtube, but
not really long shows. Uh,
so tell me what role do you think that
tissue there's of machine learning to
play weeding bias in machine
learning that any models,
prejudice or towards minorities?
It all comes back to the data.
Make sure that you have
quality diverse data, right?
Overfitting can result in the things we
see it in news where there is bias in
terms of race.
So make sure you have diverse state
and why is it machine learning called
statistical learning? It could definitely
be a, it's just, it's just brands,
right?
These are just brands and stories and
marketing and we call it different things,
but in the end it's all about
mathematical optimization.
What are your personal objectives
for the next five years?
I would like to build a content machine
and kind of like a Khan Academy for Ai
Slash Netflix for education.
That just gets really big and gets a lot
of people to watch and it makes a big,
big impact. Will be solve
intelligence in your lifetime. Um,
yes we will 100% I don't even know why
I had to think about that for a second.
Yes, we will. We will.
What is the best resource for learning
mathematics involved in machine learning
or deep learning? Uh, there's a great
deep learning book by Ian Goodfellow.
Definitely check that book out.
Also my channel for sure.
The math of intelligence series, watch
it all. Those are the two best ones.
In terms of the current market,
which jobs would you think would get
first affected by artificial intelligence?
Anything that is just people don't
like any jobs that people don't like.
So anything like call center support or a
cashiers as well. Cashiers. In
terms of the current market,
which jobs would you think would get,
I set that one 33 if you were
stranded on an island for life,
which three apps when you choose and why?
I would choose Twitter because
I absolutely love Twitter.
I would choose Facebook just because,
yeah,
social media and also read
it because I love reddit.
How important are data structures and
algorithms for machine learning will?
It leads me to be deep learning as well.
I'm a beginner.
Data structures and algorithms are
super important for anything you do in
computer science. Definitely. If you
have any interest in web development,
mobile ml,
blockchain,
just get your data structures
and algorithms in line
first and then move on to
the harder stuff. What's your view on
Elan's concern about the surgeon AI?
He's totally right.
We need to regulate it.
We need some kind of oversight in some
way to make sure that the bad actors
don't get too much power.
What's the project you've built that
you're most proud of? My Youtube Channel.
What's the one resource which helps you
get up and running quickly and machine
learning?
The machine learning sub reddit.
Do you have a circle of people you mentor
personally who claimed to grow in the
field of machine learning? If yes,
how can someone join? I don't. I,
I don't have enough time for
that right now. My channel.
I think of everybody as a group. Uh, yeah.
How do you see reinforcement learning
impacting the future in terms of practical
applications, practical
applications, reinforcement?
It's one of those emerging like it's,
it's going to have, it's the heyday.
It's not right now. Maybe it's, maybe
it's next year, maybe it's in five years.
But in terms of the first
applications, I would say it's, uh,
anything with cleaning robots or real
life robots that will do some kind of
disaster recovery or something
that humans don't want to do.
If you could go back in time with
the same knowledge you have now,
when and where would you go?
I would go back to New York to Columbia,
and I would have started
my youtube channel earlier.
Is it essentially needed when you prepare
for technical interviews to try to
solve problems on your own
without looking at solutions?
Yep.
Yeah,
for sure. Yeah. You got it. You got to
work the brain, right? It's a discipline.
You got to work the brand. The better
it gets at this algorithm stuff,
the better it's going to be for your
interviews. Okay. So Raj, you're awesome.
I want to learn about machine learning,
but I'm a complete beginner.
Could you outline a rough idea of what
I should look to do to learn machine
learning?
Just okay,
watch my learn python
for data science series.
Then watch my machine
learning for hackers series.
Then watch my intro to
deep learning series,
then watch my math of
intelligence series in that order.
What math courses have you taken?
I mean on and off,
I've taken some calculus courses,
linear Algebra here and there
online at university in high school.
But in the end you,
the best way to learn this stuff is to
just a con academy is a great resource.
Let me just put it very simply.
Use Khan Academy for your math essentials.
What do you think about the
latest achievement of open
Ai's Dota playing agent?
Oh my God, that was so bad
ass. That is very cool.
I'm so glad that open AI did
that. They are back. Uh, they
are hot right now, so um,
yeah,
I think it's awesome.
Do you think that a masters degree is
required to work in big companies or is it
bachelors and being good enough?
Being good is enough for the right
companies of course are always going to be
companies that really care
about your credentials,
but the but the best companies
care about what you can output.
So make sure you have your get
hub full of great projects.
How many hours a week do you
work in study? Oh my God,
I work at least 80 hours a week.
I am a workaholic.
I work Monday through Saturday.
I take Sunday off. Uh,
but sometimes they even work on Sunday.
Yep. Can you juggle three balls?
No.
Who is Saroj revolt?
The first of its kind.
What is intelligence? How
far are we in solving it?
Intelligence is the ability to
adapt and to learn. And we are,
I would say five to 10
years away from solving it.
What our gas generative adversarial
networks are a technique invented by Ian
Goodfellow that like you that have to
neural networks dual against each other
and the result is being able to generate
data types that have not been possible
before you were about to get into a fight.
What song comes on as your soundtrack?
Uh,
fight music by M and m.
This kind of music use it anyway.
What can you speak besides
programming ones? English. Good.
Drop the which is a dialect
from north India, Hindi,
which is the language of India. Spanish
from high school. I grew up in Houston,
Texas.
Shout out to Houston and I worked at a
flea market with my dad just selling cell
phone accessories, talks about and I
had to learn Spanish. So Spanish, Hindi.
We dropped the and I'm learning Dutch.
We'll see how that goes.
What do you ever go to Mars?
Of course I would go to Mars.
I am just waiting to go to Mars.
That's going to happen for sure. Ilan,
if you're watching this, you know, you
know what the deal is. So checking. Yeah.
How do I get into research without
a masters or a Phd? Yo. Okay.
So my thing is I am trying to
democratize research, right?
So I haven't really gone into that field,
but we're getting to a point where
anybody will be able to publish a research
online. I'm trying to grow the
amateur research community.
You don't need to have a phd
to publish valuable research.
We're going to get to that point in
terms of what the progress so far in that
field, I would say it's, um, distill.pub.
What do you do for a living?
I make youtube videos.
I make some money off of ads and Patrion
uh, and my deal with you, Udacity,
that I just did.
How do you think blockchain and AI,
it can be implemented together?
Oh my God. Great question.
Open mind by Andrew Trask.
Check that out. Great example.
File coin is another great example.
Uh,
anytime you want to create
a decentralized application,
AI can be used to make it more autonomous.
These are all tech,
blockchain and AI or just technologies
to make autonomous software.
What inspired you to get into AI?
I was traveling through India and I saw
a lot of problems that I didn't think
would be solvable in my lifetime.
And I just came to the realization that
the only way we're going to really solve
all these problems, the only real
chance we have is to solve Ai.
Your greatest inspiration. Why? Uh,
it's a tie between Kanye west for being
a creative who is unapologetic and uh,
Andrew Andrew,
what's your daily routine?
I wake up at 8:00 AM I drink some
coffee and I either I start writing and
programming and editing
and sometimes shooting.
If I'm shooting a video and I do that
until nine or 10:00 PM on and off.
Suggest some good books. You
think people should read, read.
Uh Oh. Okay. Some good
books people should read.
Read the deep learning book.
I already said that. Read, uh,
how to create a mind by Kurzweil and
one wore this a superintelligence by
Bostrom, Nick Bostrom. That was the
best advice you've ever been given.
I also sapiens by the book sapiens.
The best advice I've ever been given
is every time you have a decision,
it was actually by my hair,
my hair dresser.
He said every time you have a decision
and you think the harder choice,
the more risky choice is going
to be worse. It never is.
So just take the leap
and do the riskier thing.
What are the coolest libraries you use
often a tensorflow and also Pi torch and
I have been really getting into
decentralized applications,
so I would say truffle and
open Zeppelin and etherium.
How can deep learning help in solving
unanswered questions in biomedicine?
Yeah, I mean you could use generative
models to generate new types of medicine.
You could use discriminator model
to detect diseases that exist.
So both of those things.
What do you think about Andrew
Higgins new course on deep learning?
I think it's dope by I
support anything that he does.
We were trying to democratize AI,
so definitely check it out.
What do you think about the future
of decentralized applications?
The time is now it's happening.
And do you think machine learning and
deep learning are just overhyped by tech
giants? Can it really solve
general and Super Ai in the future?
Or is another AI winter coming,
uh, statistically speaking? Yes,
another AI winter is coming.
We don't know how long it's going to be.
Deep learning could be the path
forward. We don't know. Personally,
I think one shot learning
is going to be the,
the field that is going to be the next
step after deep learning where we need
less data for the same results.
But it's a very exciting space and as long
as we have a tension and we have hard,
hardworking people in this space,
it's going to keep,
it's going to keep up
accelerating. Cool. Well,
thanks for answering all my questions and
showing me around. Awesome. Thanks, Dan.
Yeah,
yeah.